to yonkers new york to learn more about
the beginnings of alexis de tocqueville
and his companion gustav de beaumont's
trek to upstate new york and the
american frontier
we continue with congressional views of
foreign affairs as senator joseph biden
talks about the prospects of nato
expansion
he's the senior democrat on the foreign
relations committee and was at the
atlantic council of the u.s on wednesday
he discussed the applications of three
central european countries to enter nato
and offered his assessment of the
senate's approval
his remarks are an hour and fifteen
minutes
good afternoon
senator biden is just here from a vote
on the senate floor
and
so
would like for us to get started right
away
it's a particular pleasure and honor for
me to
be able
to introduce senator biden this
afternoon when i was
what i thought still then was a fairly
young general counsel of the senate
armed services committee in 1973
he came to the senate younger by several
years than i at age
29
elected in 1972 from delaware
and now in his fifth term
has established himself as one of the
leading and most important senators
member of either body in both the areas
of judiciary and foreign policy
particularly relevant to our
considerations here this afternoon
senator biden is now
ranking democrat on the senate foreign
relations committee and has
served as both chairman and ranking
democrat on the european affairs
subcommittee
and over the years in addition to his
superb service on judiciary issues and
other foreign policy issues has taken a
particular interest in europe
serving on the nato observer group as
co-chairman and as vice chairman of the
senate delegation to the north atlantic
assembly
these are undertakings which
frankly
are
much more important than they are
visible
they
involve the heart of the countries and
the congress's work
on what has been for many years our
central alliance
and our major international tool
in winning as we did the cold war
but service in these capacities normally
does not bring a great deal of press
it is service by individuals who do it
who love the united states and who
wanted to do what was necessary in order
to
make a real difference in the cold war
and in relations among our allies
senator biden in this capacity as well
as in his recent leadership on bosnia
and on a number of other issues has
shown himself
to be one of those people in the senate
who makes a difference and does so with
hard slogging work
as well as
work that from time to time of course
gets uh excellent press attention but
this is a senator who deserves
everyone's gratitude for the way in
which he goes about representing his
state and the united states as a whole i
had the particular pleasure when i
negotiated the cfe treaty
for a republican administration to
have him be the chairman of the
subcommittee that dealt with the treaty
and saw his thoroughness and his
professionalism in the national interest
on a daily basis for some weeks
he also to top it all off
is
lives outside washington in delaware
commutes daily to his home and family
and therefore has a normal life rather
than the life of this crazy
hot house city
in
many many ways
all of us are
quite lucky and deeply grateful for the
fact that joe biden is in the senate
senator biden thank you
thank you very much jim i uh
hey how you doing man
i question what do you know about
foreign policy what are you doing here
i don't know anything either so we're
both we'll be in good company there's a
man i spent about uh
one third of my adult life with on the
judiciary committee dealing with the
reagan administration and a man who i
have
enormous regard for um
and he would be the first to tell you
that
it is only someone in washington can say
that someone who voluntarily commutes
250 miles a day for 24 years is normal
um
[Laughter]
i i that's the highest compliment i've
received in a long long time i
i want you to know and i i do appreciate
it
uh ladies and gentlemen it's an honor to
be invited to speak to such a
distinguished group you hear that often
stated but it is true you are a
distinguished group and
and some of
you have
have been toiling in this arena long
before i've gotten involved and almost
all of you have been toiled in it with
greater success than i have as long as
i've been involved and so i'm i'm
grateful that you give me the
opportunity to uh to come and speak with
you tonight
uh and i'd like to thank you again
admiral for that kind introduction and
it's a it's a pleasure and an honor uh
to uh to be in your company for decades
you've been
this entire organization
has been a pillar of support for the
north atlantic alliance
and that support in my view is now
as important as it ever has been
although i as i'm going to attempt to
outline tonight
i
think some of you will be surprised to
learn i believe
it is going to be very much in jeopardy
uh during this period of change and
transition my topic this evening this
evening is the enlargement of the north
atlantic treaty organization to include
several new democratic central european
countries and ladies and gentlemen
i propose to divide my talk if you'll
allow me into two parts first outline my
support for enlargement and i came to
this somewhat more skeptical than most
and second uh in addition to outlining
why
i support it to uh to go on
and go out on the limb and attempt to
give you uh a prognosis of senatorial
attitudes and outcomes on this issue uh
as it unfolds over the next year
explaining the rationale for nato
enlargement to group like this is a
truly preaching to the choir at least
explaining the rationale for nato his
continued uh vibrance is uh preaching to
the choir i expect there's some division
within this room about enlargement a
whether we should and b if we should how
we should and who should be
included
but
just so you know that your elected
representatives are not
plunging blindly forward allow me to
review
some of the arguments against
enlargement and then explain why i do
not find them convincing but i suspect
you're going to hear these arguments
much more
loudly and forcefully articulated on the
floor than i respectfully suggest any of
you think
the first of the arguments is that and i
believe the senate at least today is
basically divided into
three groups of senators
on this issue those who uh uh who are uh
uh believe that nato uh is uh not only
has been but continues to be essential
to our security interest and that it is
not a question of whether or not it
remains the same or expands but does it
expand or does it die um and
that basically is one group of which i
count myself a member there's a second
group out there that says that nato is
important nato is important enlargement
of it is not so important uh because uh
we are applying uh in their view a
disproportionate share of our resources
to europe uh and uh and that uh we
should begin to uh to reallocate uh um
our resources in terms of our overall
worldwide security interest and europe
is not the most important game in town
anymore and there's a third group who
simply believe that uh
and there are few in my party and a few
more in the republican party who are
neo-isolationists who basically believe
we should withdraw
from the world in a whole range of areas
not the least of which is nato and uh
and so the arguments that i will outline
that i most often hear now in the cloak
room and here now privately in my
conversations my colleagues sort of
break down this way
one
is that the soviet union is but a bad
memory and no military threat is in
sight in europe so why the hell do we
have to do any of this the second is the
pacific rim has become the world's
premier area for economic growth so we
shouldn't concentrate so many resources
in europe we should be concentrating in
significant larger portion of our
resources in the pacific grim
the third is a latin america while also
a prime opportunity for trade investment
is more important than europe to the
united states because of our problems of
illegal immigration and drug trafficking
and other matters and greater
opportunities exist as i pointed out in
a recent trip when i was being lectured
as we always are
by europeans about why we have the
obligation to do what we're doing
i happen to agree that they're right but
i don't like the lectures um i could not
resist pointing out to one particular
prime minister that his country's
population combined with all the other
likely candidates did not equal that of
mexico and the consequences of trade
opportunities with his country paled in
comparison to mexico and he wasn't
nearly as important
as mexico
i still find myself trying to resist
being as irreverent and as irrational
but i couldn't resist it because i got
tired of lecture
but the truth of the matter is an awful
lot of my colleagues feel that very very
very deeply
so when we make these trade arguments we
make the security arguments they look a
latin american say wait a minute it's a
hell of a lot more important what
happens in mexico than any of the
countries you're talking about and so um
the and the last argument i most often
hear is nato enlargement may assist the
nationalists and the communists in
russia and draw new dividing lines in
europe i will uh in one case uh it's
it's sort of the be unfair to say the
kennen argument but the the notion of a
new dividing line and this is going to
embolden
all those forces in the in russia that
we do not want to see in boulder
these are legitimate assertions that i
think have to be answered and will be
the subject debate on the senate floor
i would submit first of all without
minimizing the importance of asia or
latin america that europe remains a
vital area of interest for the united
states for political strategic and
economic and cultural reasons
as
a sizable percentage of the world's
democracies are in europe and the
continent remains a major global
economic player in a partner of the
united states
in economic terms the european union
with a combined population a third
larger than ours has a combined gdp that
exceeds ours and while the united states
as a larger and i might add a less
balanced trading relationship with asia
than with europe we invest far more in
europe
several new democracies in central and
eastern europe
are are highly have highly educated
workforces already boast rapidly
expanding economies and already attract
considerable american investment and
moreover most americans trace their
cultural roots to europe and millions
retain personal ties to it and by any
geopolitical standard it would be a
catastrophe for the united states
interest if instability were to alter
the current situation in europe
now how might this instability occur
well no one that i know who is even
mildly informed believes that the
russian army is uh posed to pour through
the fuller gap in germany nato's horror
scenario for the previous uh 40 years
the russian army is in such pitiful
shape that couldn't even uh i might
obviously could not even reconquer
chechnya as part of the russian
federation
and so
no uh in my view the threats to
stability in europe have changed but
they are if anything even more real than
those of the cold war
we all know what they are
they are the ethnic and religious
hatreds as horrifyingly shown and
hundreds of thousands killed raped and
made homeless and or otherwise
brutalized in bosnia they are the
well-organized forces of international
crime whose tentacles extend from moscow
to palermo to new york to los angeles
and true but some might ask why the
europeans can't take care of their own
problems
well life's not fair
and europe in my view and i'm going to
get in trouble for saying this has not
developed a degree of political
maturation on the continent where
they're likely to be able to settle
their serious problems on the continent
without without at least an allocator
and in most cases a very firm and strong
voice from the united states
unfortunately the history of the 20th
century has demonstrated that the united
states must play a leading role in
organizing the security of europe in
world war one and world war ii and
lately in bosnia without american
leadership the countries of europe have
been unable to resolve their differences
peacefully
while american idealism has certainly
played a role in our various
interventions to rescue europe
enlightened self-interest has been the
dominant motive i need not tell anyone
in this room put simply it's in the
vital interest of the united states that
stability be preserved in europe
in order for us to be able to play the
constructive role in latin america and
in the pacific rim in the rest of the
world
now how does this translate into 1997
terms
it means that we must lead europe to
create what is called in current policy
jargon a new security architecture
president clinton has a phrase he loves
to use i think he's right we are the
essential nation
i see no reasonable possibility that a
new security architecture is likely to
be able to be created
without the involved and firm hand of
the united states
and it's needed in my view to guarantee
the stability to the areas most
vulnerable to disruption over the past
90 years
to no one's surprise i'm talking about
central and eastern europe where newly
independent states are striving to
create and solidify
political democracy and free market
economies
and it's a very difficult process
which if not put into a larger framework
could spin out of control and i might
note parenthetically i happen to be with
the prime minister of romania today and
he was talking about the economic
changes that were made and how some in
this country that he's visiting are
indicating that they haven't done enough
and i said well as one politician
together let me remind you what you've
done is remarkable the question is
whether it will last whether the
commitment is is real and it will be
sustained but
don't let anyone in this country lecture
you here you have a country that's
vibrant and healthy and growing and
democrats and republicans and the
president couldn't even get together and
agreed to take the courageous step of
recalculating the cpi
that would impact up one half to one and
one half percent on future growth of
pension benefits in the united states
so tell when anyone starts to lecture
you uh tell them to spare you the
lecture and uh and uh point to that just
as i hope you'll spare me the lecture
about our obligation uh uh to you uh um
uh and uh and we recent accord um
and uh it's in this context of
enlightenment of that nato must be seen
i believe
during world war during the cold war
nato provided a security umbrella which
former enemies like france and germany
were able to cooperate under which
former enemies like france and germany
were able to cooperate and build highly
successful free societies
it was the framework in which
the former prize of like italy and
germany and spain could be reintegrated
into democratic europe and it was nato
that kept
kept the feud between greece and turkey
from escalating into warfare
the enlargement of nato in my view can
can now serve to move that zone of
stability eastward to central europe
and thereby both prevent ethnic
conflicts from escalating and forestall
a a scramble for new bilateral and
multilateral pacts along the lines of
the 1930s from occurring
in fact it's already happening in
anticipation of nato membership several
central and east european countries have
recently settled long-standing disputes
i need only mentioned hungary and
romania slovenia and italy germany and
the czech republic poland and lithuania
romania and ukraine and so on
if nato were not
if nato were not to enlarge however the
countries between germany and russia in
my view would inevitably seek other
means to protect themselves
the question for today is not in my view
as i stated earlier as is often assumed
enlarged nato will remain the same
for the status quo is simply not an
option in my view
ladies and gentlemen there is one
additional argument for nato enlargement
which may have fallen out of fashion
and that is a moral one
for 40 years the united states loudly
proclaimed its solidarity with the
captive nations of central and eastern
europe
who were under the heel of the communist
oppressor
now that most of them have cast off
their shackles it's our responsibility
to live up to our pledges to readmit
them into the west through nato and the
european union when they are fully
qualified
ironically
within the fruits of nato's unparalleled
success lie the seeds for its possible
demise
alliances are formed to fight wars or to
deter them
once the adversary is gone unless
alliances adapt to meet changing threats
they lose their reason for being
thus
enlargement in my view must be
accompanied by a redefinition of nato's
mission
the alliance's primary mission as
outlined in article 5 of the washington
treaty of april 4 1949 remains the same
treating an attack on one member as an
attack on all and responding through the
use of armed forces if necessary
now
in the current post-war post-cold war
situation non-article 5 missions like
peacekeeping sometimes in cooperation
with non-nato powers have become
possible
the s4 joint effort in bosnia with
russia and several other non-nato
countries i believe is an excellent
example of this
but what about our our erstwhile
adversary russia
i firmly believe that nato enlargement
need not adversely affect the u.s
relationship with russia
i came to this conclusion on a trip to
moscow and several central european
countries earlier this spring
although few russians i found anywhere
from the think tank folks to the
officials in power
although few russians
are fond of nato enlargement policy
makers in moscow accepted it moreover no
russian politician with whom i met from
communist leaders of gonov to liberal
leader yelinski to nationalist leader
levin believe that nato enlargement
constitutes a security threat to their
country i did not find a single official
left right or center who believed that
to be the case
in fact nearly all politicians and i met
with a number of members of the doom as
well
all politicians and experts with whom i
met understood the non-aggressiveness
implicit in nato's three nos the
alliance's declaration of having no
reason intention or plan
in the current and foreseeable security
environment permanently to station
nuclear weapons or substantial combat
forces of current members on the
territory of new member states they all
understood that
and i don't think any of them doubted
that with whom i spoke
rather the kremlin's public opposition
to enlargement in my view is largely a
question of a psychological problem they
are undergoing now
connected with the loss of empire
wounded pride and most importantly
uncertainty about russia's place in the
world of the 21st century
and were you in their spot you would be
the same in my view and i would
where do they go i had one interesting
comment our conversation was that gone
off was repeated with levitt they talked
about they don't want this nato
expansion they know it's not in their
security interests and on and on and
said well and if you do that we may have
to look to china
and i couldn't help using the colloquial
expression for my state by saying to
zaghanov lots of luck in your senior
year um you know uh good luck and if not
if that doesn't work try iran um and uh
i'm serious i said that to them and
these were
and and and they know i knew they knew
everybody knows
that that is not an option and everybody
knows every one of those leaders
acknowledges and needs and they resent
it
but they need they need to look west
and the question is with this is
designed to completely shut them out
but not in terms of whether or not is a
direct military security threat
rather the kremlin's public opposition
as i said is largely a psychological
question
and an uncertainty about his place in
the world of the 21st century
as part of this uncertainty most russian
leaders are worried about their country
being marginalized and as a result they
are eager to move forward with bilateral
relations with the united states
and let's not kid ourselves never is a
long time
and russia's current weakened condition
is sure to improve
and in my view that means we must
continue to
engage russia politically
militarily and economically the clinton
administration together with our nato
allies has already begun to do this
time does not permit me to go into
detail and most of you know the detail
of the nato russian founding act signed
in paris
except for me to say at this point that
it's a good start
at binding russia closer to the west and
soothing his bruised feelings without
without giving moscow a decision-making
role in nato's core structure like the
north atlantic council
the purely consultative mandate of the
new nato-russia joint council however
does not mean that it cannot evolve into
a truly valuable mechanism for promoting
mutual trust
as russian officials better understand
that nato is not there this rapacious
caricature of the soviet propaganda
but rather a defensive alliance and a
force for security and stability in
europe their animosity toward the
organization may dissipate and if we do
it well i believe it will
and by working together with the joint
council russia can prove that it is a
responsible partner for the west to
continue to deal with
through this mechanism and others over
time
moscow can come to realize that
enlargement of nato by moving the zone
of stability eastward to central europe
will in fact increase russia's own
security
i have an expression that i often use in
terms of domestic politics i never tell
another man is politics so i don't
presume to tell the russian political
leadership what they should think but i
truly believe that it is in russia's
interest for this zone of stability to
be extended rather than nothing to
happen
in order for nato enlargement to proceed
though both our current allies and the
candidate countries invited to john to
join at the madrid summit next month
must agree
they must agree the 15 other nato
nations and the three if that's what the
number is four or five and i believe it
will be three if the three
nations are going to come in they must
agree to shoulder their fair share of
the financial cost and all the mutual
obligations that should be undertaken
this is not a sorority or fraternity
this is not a club this is not a social
undertaking this is a serious serious
undertaking as i need not tell a single
person here
but i find among the populations and
among the press and among academics in
the countries i've visited many of them
are looking at this more in terms of
their their anchor in the west than
anything having to do with any
obligation their contemplated
undertaking the financial cost of
undertaking the obligation or the
military consequences
candidates for membership in nato must
assume the financial burden of making
their armed forces interoperable with
those of nato members in addition to
meeting the cost of modernism
modernizing their militaries which they
must undertake in any event
other obligations exist
other obligations are political and
military such as agreeing to come to the
aid of allies as described in article 5
allowing basing of nato troops on their
territory if necessary and allowing
overflights of nato aircraft if
necessary
the february 1997 pentagon study
on on nato excuse me
proposed
a distribution of direct cost of
enlargement
whereby 15 percent would be assumed by
the united states 35 percent by the new
members
and 50 percent by other current members
of nato
calculating these ratios begins with the
estimate that about 40 percent of the
direct enlargement
excuse me enlargement enhancement could
be nationally funded
and 60 percent
common funded
estimated direct cost of enlargement
totaled between 9 and 12 billion dollars
over 12 years through the year 2009
let me point out the critical fact that
according to the pentagon plan it is
only these direct costs these direct
costs that the united states would help
pay for
additionally costs not directly related
to enlargement would have to be paid for
by our current allies and our new allies
for example
our current allies must develop power
projections capabilities which the
united states achieved in the 1980s if
they are to contribute to the new
mission of the alliance
while these capabilities will allow them
to help defend new members
they are necessary even if nato were not
to enlarge it's estimated that they will
cost 8 to 10 billion over 12 years
candidate countries must make the
financial means available to modernize
their forces and achieve
interoperability within nato if they
expect current members to ratify their
recession to membership
as i told one official in the country i
will not mention because i don't want to
get 500 letters
if you want to fly first class i've kept
being tolerant we want first-class
first-class membership
and i finally said to this military
leader if you want to fly first class
you have to buy a first-class ticket
this is not a charity operation
the
the expected u.s contribution to the
direct cost of the enlargement of nato
are estimated at 150 to 200 million
dollars per year for 10 years if
if
the 15 other nato nations pick up 50
percent of the cost
a big if in my view
although a small fraction of our total
national budget it's nonetheless not
trivial given our mandate to balance the
u.s federal budget by the year 2002
and that brings me directly to my second
point the second point of my talk
that is the prospects for senate
ratification of nato enlargement
you may be surprised when i tell you and
i may be the only one to tell you
that i expect it to be an extremely
difficult fight
everyone else thinks it's going to be a
cakewalk so i hope i'm wrong
but the only thing i think most of the
few of you who know me here know i may
not be good at much but i ain't bad at
knowing the senate
after 24 years i figured it out
and i'm telling you i think it's going
to be one hell of a fight
even if the senate ratifies enlargement
i have grave worries about the continued
american commitment to nato in the
coming years
unrelated to enlargement
my reasons for pessimism revolve around
three sides of the same issue
burden-sharing
the first side relates to the sharing
cost of nato enlargement the second side
relates to sharing military duties in
bosnia and the third relates to the
european union's foot dragging in my
view on its own enlargement in the
central and eastern europe
first the cost
i fear that the 50 share of direct
enlargement cost allocated to the
western european nato partners in canada
may be politically more difficult than
the 35 percent allocated to the new
members particularly after our current
allies pay for their own power
projection enhancements
to be blunt the europeans face a number
of competing priorities eleven european
nato members who are also members of the
european union are currently engulfed in
a painful budget cutting in order to
meet the maastricht convergence criteria
for economic and monetary union
on january of 91 of 1999.
those countries who qualify may be held
a rigid fiscal discipline thereafter and
if a stability pack is enforced without
so-called political criteria there's a
problem
resentment against this belt tightening
played a key role in the defeat of
president sharok's coalition in the
french elections on june the first
as a politician
i i empathize with the challenge our
european friends face
but we all have to make difficult
choices and if our european allies want
continued american involvement in their
security they're going to have to step
up to the plate
in order for nato remain to remain a
vibrant organization with the united
states continuing to play the lead role
the non-us members must assume their
fair share of the direct enlargement
cost and for developing power projection
capabilities in the environment in which
they now find themselves
to do otherwise would cast the united
states in the role of the uh the good
john darm of europe a role that neither
the american people nor the senate of
the united states i believe would be
willing to accept
above and beyond enlargement unless our
european allies significantly upgrade
their militaries a strategic disconnect
between a technologically superior
united states military and a
technologically outdated western
european militaries will make it
impossible for nato to function as it
has in the past 40 years
my sentiments have been voiced by
several of my colleagues including some
who do not share my passionate
commitment to continued american
involvement in europe
as co-chairman of a rather unwieldy
group of 28 senators known as the senate
nato observer group senator roth is the
chairman i want you to know nato
enlargement is going to be decided in
delaware it's an all delaware deal
but last week all kidding aside this
group met with the president united
states the vice president the secretary
of state the national security advisor
and one of the deputy chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff
and i assure you i'm not betraying any
confidence or national secrets when i
tell you that the president vice
president and others got an earful
from my colleagues
from
some of our group
they got an ear full those who feared
dilution of nato's effectiveness by
adding new members
a surprisingly large number of that
group
voiced that concern
either asserted it was going to happen
or voiced the concern it may
from some who uh had up to uh uh had it
up to here with uh european allies uh
not pulling their weight in their
opinion i think that was the phrase used
had it up to here
from some who uh reminded us that six of
the seven largest armies of the world
are in asia
not in europe
from some who pointed out that north
east asia and south asia not europe are
the two areas of the world where nuclear
conflict is most likely to break out
and from still others
from just one or two who just were plain
tired of the united states being
responsible for as one of them said nine
one one calls from around the world
my friends
were in for a real fight
and a group of some of the most
important and influential senators just
came back from a recent trip to brussels
and i don't think i'm
i'm confident i'm not saying i shouldn't
when i say ted stevens one of the most
informed people one of the people who
heretofore has been most committed to
nato
has gone from not certain to skeptic
to almost i don't know this for sure i
can't say it for certain but as he
button-holed me he said you know
everything you said about what to say is
right and we've i'm telling you i'm not
this a bad idea
now what bad idea he is referring to i
wasn't sure
but i believe he means
the expansion of nato
so this is not a rump group of
uninformed people who haven't been
involved in foreign policy matters who
are going to say you know i'm not sure
this is a good idea
i think you're going to see i think
you're going to see
some real spirited debate
and as if this weren't going to be
enough trouble
there is a second dark cloud
looming on the horizon of
european-american relations
and that is in the late spring of 1998
just when the senate is likely to be
voting on amending the washington treaty
to accept new members
american ground forces will be
completing their withdrawal from bosnia
as announced and i believe it should
have never been announced but i am in a
minority of about three in the united
states senate
i mean i'm not exaggerating that i don't
think there i understand why the
administration did what they did if they
hadn't they probably would have been
overwhelmed by
two efforts i was able to help
successfully stop
being legislated in the senate
setting a drop dead date as a matter of
legislative law of a matter of
legislation
but nonetheless notwithstanding the fact
i think it's a bad bad idea
for us making that announcement in that
judgment ahead of time
i do think the politician in me tells me
that it's likely to happen
i don't know how the boy gets out of
this one
i don't know how he moves from this one
and i'm being a bit facetious obviously
but i don't know how
we get off of this
and it's going to occur
at the very time
of the very time we're going to be
voting
on whether or not to amend the treaty
as it now stands our european allies
will follow suit
repeating the in together out together
mantra
despite the u.s offer to make air naval
communications and intelligence assets
available to a european-led follow-on
force with an american rapid reaction
force on standby alert over the horizon
in hungary or in italy
many of my colleagues mindful of the uh
the repeated calls by some european nato
members led by france for more european
leadership in the alliance
and a sturdier european pillar in nato
we'll see in the european refusal to
main train maintain troops in bosnia
evidence of an equitable burden sharing
or worse still will have doubts about
the worth of nato in the first place
i might note parenthetically some of you
are tired of hearing me say this had
been a broken record for five years
failure to move more enlightened way in
my view on bosnia
did more damage to the likelihood of the
united nations being able to play a
significant role in our foreign policy
calculations and nato's long-term
viability than anything that's happened
in the last five years
but the point here is very basic and i'm
sure you fully understand it i have a
friend i went to high school with very
bright guy he's
he has what they call street smarts and
i'll sometimes say i said bob now do you
understand what i mean
and he'll look at me and said joe i not
only understand i overstand
well i'm sure you all overstand the
point that i'm making but it bears
repeating
it bears repeating in terms of the
political context in which this battle
is going to take place
that's why i might add parenthetically
that and i have given unsolicited advice
worth what they have paid for it to the
secretary of state to the president
national security adviser that instead
of spending time up in the united states
senate trying to convince these
erstwhile these these way wayward
members about whether or not to vote for
enlargement they should be spending time
in the european capitals making sure
that 50 percent number is really going
to be forthcoming
and they should be spending time in
european capitals trying to work out
some kind of accommodation
so it's not
all in all out
it's not an easy mission i might add i'm
not suggesting that just to go say it
means it can be done
but that's where i'd be spending my
capital in my energy where i the
secretary of state or the president
rather than up on capitol hill
the french position in bosnia
if you pardon the pun i find
particularly galling
considering
considering their insistence on the
european command of armed forces south
of naples
as you know aft south is the home of the
sixth fleet
and no matter how paris tries to dress
it up senators perceive this demand as a
gratuitous poke in the eye
aside from the fact that it's a
non-starter of an idea it contributes to
poisoning the atmosphere particularly
since our german allies as usual have at
least formally supported the french
although privately i doubt they agree at
all
the final matter concerns the
enlargement of the european union
from the early 1990s the eu firmly
proclaimed that nato enlargement had to
precede eu expansion if
a session two years ago of austria
finland and sweden is accepted with an e
i'm well aware of the uh the complexity
of
melding the political economic and to
some extent the social systems of
divergent countries into
in eu language an ever closer union
but many observers and
not a few of my colleagues suspect that
to some extent the eu has yielded to
domestic pressure groups like the
farmers and has used nato enlargement as
a convenient way to postpone the
admission of central and eastern
european countries to put it crudely for
now nato should have to serve
for now nato should serve as a poor
man's eu
and that's where i think they're looking
how many of our european allies are
looking at
now uh that nato is a set 1999 date for
completion of the first round of
enlargement the eu should move ahead
with its own expansion and the first
round target date of 2 2002 has been
cited and should be met
in the meantime as president clinton
advocated three weeks ago in the hague
western governments and private
enterprises should cooperate on
investment mechanisms to assist the
economies of the new democracies to move
rapidly forward
this may sound simplistic
but
but likely attempts at unequal cost
sharing of nato enlargement
unwillingness for a rational division of
labor in bosnia after mid 1999 and the
slogo policy of you eu expansion which
would greatly benefit eastern europe all
seem to many senators to be variants of
taking the united states for suckers
so how about my prognosis well i think
the debate will be lively occasionally
raw but necessary
i think that in the end it will be very
difficult for most of my colleagues to
vote against admitting the polls the
czechs and the hungarians into nato
but i also believe that unless we
quickly come to a satisfactory
burden-sharing understanding in all its
facets with our european and canadian
allies the future of nato in the next
century will be very much in doubt
let me conclude by saying
many of us here
came from through and were involved in
what is referred to now as seems like a
hundred years ago that vietnam era and
the vietnam generation we could all
argue what lessons we should or should
not have learned from vietnam but i
suspect there's one most of us would
agree on and that is that no foreign
policy regardless of how
well fashioned and how brilliantly laid
out can be sustained without the
informed consent of the american people
the informed consent of the american
people
thus far the american people have not
only not been asked to give their
consent they have not been informed as
to the cost and obligations and benefits
of expanding
and so i truly believe that although
this
debate will be rambunctious at times
ill-informed at times
it will also be
abs the absolute precondition
for the ability of the united states to
sustain its commitment to nato as it is
or expand it
and i believe once the case is made to
the american people they will sign on
but i want to make it real clear to
everybody here
that
as we vote
there will be few senators who will vote
no on poland
but i want to make sure when they vote
yes they also raise their hand and say
and i understand that commits me for the
next 10 years
to appropriate
another couple hundred million dollars a
year
because the worst of all worlds in my
view is expand nato
and then end up in the kind of debate we
had for the last five years about the
united nations
whether or not we should pay
withholding our commitment
that will unlike
the u.n which can and did bumble along
and i don't i'm not say that critically
but bumble along for the past five or
six years
nato will not do that
and so we have to be prepared for all
those
we talk about and ultimately vote for
the inclusion of these three new nations
the most likely candidates
that they have signed on and have told
their constituents
that they're going to have to pay
and that they will vote to pay
i said there was a last thing there's
actually one more
i wrote a report which any of you who
have insomnia
might i brought along as presumptuous
for me to do this in this group but i
brought along copies of the report i
spent a lot of time on it with dr hatzel
when we came back
i um
and i point out two things as i pointed
out to each of the
each of the candidate states and i met
with the heads of state of every one of
them every major elected political
official in each of those countries
it was clear to me after the first day
that none of the countries in question
had any clear notion of the cost to them
none of them
none of them had any clear
notion of the cost of that with some
good reason because of that the missions
had been not outlined to them they had
not been invited i'm not being critical
i'm just making a statement of fact as
of four weeks ago not a single solitary
country of the four that i visited
poland hungary the czech republic of
slovenia had any clear notion
of the cost the financial cost to them
and notwithstanding the fact there are
public opinion polls in poland
particularly that overwhelmingly support
nato i repeatedly asked the question
when you are making these significant
cuts in an antiquated military to
accommodate the expansion needed within
the military
do your people have any notion
of the social cost and consequences of
those decisions for you
and i pointed out again we have a base
closure commission folks
in a healthy vibrant oldest democracy in
the world
and it is wrenching it is a wrenching
political undertaking
and these nations are going to be asking
their constituencies
to make some very difficult choices
and so
i am equally as emphatic
with our
the states we're likely to invite to
join
that they as they say take the show on
the road
to make it clear that they
are willing and able
to meet the commitments that will be
required
because again let me conclude where i
began
this is not a social club
this is not a feel-good organization
this is not something that's designed to
reinforce people's sense of security
it's real live vibrant important and
critical
and there are prices
to be paid for membership but i think
the benefits for them as well as us
far outweigh the cost
and enlargement of nato all right thank
you very much and with your permission
we said we would go until 7 30 and
that's about 25 minutes from now so uh
the senator will take your questions
till then
yes sir
john karcz slovak world congress
among other things i write for slovak
american paper and when you introduced
your amendment
uh for membership to slovenia
i after the article appeared i had a
number of calls that
senator biden misspelled slovakia
and i assure them
he did not
uh did you
no i didn't know i i i know the answer
uh however i seriously i do this is true
but i do want to ask you and you
mentioned slovenia again that you had
visited what happened the senate
accepted your amendment unanimously i
believe but the administration let you
down with slovenia and what about other
countries and is there a timetable for
ongoing membership the answer to the
question is twofold one
the administration did which is not
always the case with democrat or
republican administrations did consult
with us along the way and upfront
i need not tell anyone in this room
there is a good deal of divergence
within europe
about who and when and how quickly
the combination it seemed quite frankly
at the end of the day the choice was not
three or four it was three or five
or maybe three or five plus something
and the conclusion that was reached by
the administration and i cannot quarrel
with it because i'm not the one in bonn
or in i i'm not the one in paris or
london doing the negotiating
i cannot quarrel with it
it seems to me that
the administration
if the choice was three or five or more
now made the right choice for two
reasons
for two reasons
i think it should have been four it
should have been easy it would have been
but that's a different question
the reason i think they in made the
right choice if we move
beyond slovakia
the ability to connect with the american
people in the senate on this enlargement
issue diminishes
i did i say slovakia
let me let me let me restate
because maybe i did say it the wrong way
if we move beyond
poland hungary the czech republic
and slovenia a country of two million
people if we move beyond that
as pointed out by two of my colleagues
in the meeting with the president
the
consensus in the senate
for enlarging nato
becomes is put more in question
the american people understand the moral
historical and cultural commitment they
have to poland because there's so many
american polls they understand about
hungary in 1956 they have a memory
about these countries
and they have a commitment that can be
in my view
can be awakened
and can be justified and can be
mentioned
as we expand the number as two of my
colleagues said and to be honest you i
had not thought of this
the ability to generate that kind of
consensus diminishes
now that leads to the second question
though does that mean that there's only
going to be one round
the answer to that question is
absolutely no because i think once
they've made the judgment that expansion
is necessary as a consequence of the
arguments and the integration takes
place
then i think the second and third rounds
become much easier
now again this is a tactical question
this is a judgment question i do not
presume to suggest to you what i am
suggesting the administration suggests
that their variant is in fact absolutely
right
no one in this room knows but part of
the calculation
was reception by the senate
part of the calculation was reception by
our european allies and part of the
calculation was uncertainty about the
readiness of the other countries
europeans were pushing
in terms of whether or not they have
already met the perry principles and
whether or not the changes that have
been undertaken are as real or as
permanent as they are presently real
so the conclusion
spurred on by the joint chiefs i might
add
was three
even though some of us argued
vociferously that it before
but that i don't think is a real option
and to be honest with you as i came back
from slovenia it was pretty clear to me
after meeting with some of my french
friends and others that it was not
likely to be
slovenia without
one or more in addition and so i think
you're asking me i don't know what went
into the mind of the president and
making the final decision my guess is
my guess is my educated guess is it's
the issues that i just raised
receptiveness in the senate
receptiveness in europe and the option
being not three or four but three or
five or three or six or seven
along with cost
yes sir
tom hudson's with association to unite
the democracies it just seems to me that
there are two good reasons for bringing
slovenia in
one
it creates a land path to hungary
hungary is going to be out there
isolated
number two
it
is an example for the other yugoslav
nations that maybe they can get in if
they can straighten up sir i uh
i'm not being solicitous and i say this
precisely the argument i've made to the
president precisely the argument i've
been making it let me be let me put a
finer point on it
i think that
the situation on croatia is dangerous
right now
i think mr tushman is
i'll just say is no box of chocolates i
uh i think that the road that croatia is
moving down is potentially disastrous
and i think that slovenia being admitted
now would do precisely what you said
indicate that there is a path to the
west
that is tied directly to positive
democratic
action
and settling your disputes with your
neighbors
so i think it would have been very very
strong secondly i do not think sir
bringing in slovenia would have had the
encirclement argument you know we're
going to encircle we're going to enhance
the the the uh the indecision and the
anxiety and the anger in russia etc
bringing in slovenia would have been a
nonstop i mean it would not even have
registered on the richter scale
and thirdly um i think the geo the g the
geographic point you made is a real one
although i think in the near term it's
not of much consequence in terms of its
uh its actual practical military uh
efficacy um but for all the reasons you
stated plus some you have not stated i
thought it would have been the wisest
thing to do
let me you didn't ask this but let me
add some things
i did ask the president in this last
meeting whether notwithstanding the fact
that slovenia may not be at it romania
will not may not be added and so on
whether or not the president would view
it as helpful or hurtful
if some of us in the senate upon the
decision having been made
in madrid and assume for the moment and
i don't know this obviously but assume
for the moment the decision is what we
all anticipate the so-called big three
would it be helpful or hurtful
to the president united states to art to
the united states for me or others to
introduce a resolution in the senate
saying that we hoped and expected
that the next round would come quickly
and that romania and slovenia would be
the first to on the list
and the answer interestingly enough was
it would be helpful not hurtful
so there is no question in my mind
that the second will come there will be
a second round assuming the first is
successfully negotiated
which i believe ultimately it will be
ultimately will be
also today my discussions with the prime
minister of romania
as many of you know very very well i
mean i feel kind of silly even saying
these things you all know them so well
the
prime minister is seeking romania is
seeking that there be an official
communique at madrid
that raises other questions
difficult questions
about whether or not it's a who you
leave out
i'm kind of i teach constitutional law
on saturday mornings at barton
university law school a course on
separation of powers and i'm always we
start this separations course by trying
to explain uh how we came about this old
constitution and wasn't like it came
right after the revolution there was a
thing called the articles of
confederation for a while and all those
boys who met up there in philadelphia
they sat down and they all were
instructed that by the way go try to
work it out but no new deal
no new deal in this no no new document
everybody forgets they were ordered by
their state legislators no new document
so how did it happen
how to get there
well and then i talk about this issue
about
this how about a bill of rights
and the big argument and the ninth
amendment was supposed to satisfy
although judge burke doesn't agree with
me um uh was
whether or not
by mentioning certain rights you were
implying that the rest of the rights
were not reserved to the people
well that's kind of where we are and we
start naming
we start naming future
admittees what about the balts
what about a lot of other countries who
may or may not or are seeking admission
so uh um i think the answer lies
in
one senate going on record
and two
a robust effort on the part of the
administration
to further
enhance bilateral relationships with the
country seeking admission particularly
through the partnership for peace
because i think what is going to be
needed most is an assurance that you're
still in the game
you're still in the game
and mean it
um and but this is not going to be an
easy process
again i need not tell any of you that
but it's not going to be yes general
senator uh
i agree 100 with your uh
prepared remarks and would not always
agree on 100 percent as you know
starting to lose your reputation you're
the reason we have a chemical weapons
treaty and uh um and you're agreeing
with me now i i will as jim eastland
said when i once asked him he said to me
he said boy he said what would jim
eastland do for you in delaware and i
said what do you mean mr chairman he
said if i campaigned for it what would
it do i said well some places you'd help
and some places you'd hurt and he looked
at me and swear to god true story and
looked at me and said well boy i'll come
and campaign for you against you
whichever help the
most um
so if you'd like me to say bad things
about you general i'll say him but i
don't mean him
no uh the the
thing i'd like you to elaborate on more
is
with this persuasive argument that
you've made and say with which i agree
completely
why
are you pessimistic about the
outcome why why the opposition is it
costs
other things that
must be overcome i think it's cost
resentment
resentment which is a big factor i think
we underestimate it
and
priorities
there literally are a new generation of
look
i i find this bizarre i that i'm talking
about a new generation
um but it's painfully true there is a
new generation of leadership in the
united states senate that's come in
mostly new members west of the
mississippi who general they don't look
to europe they look in every way east
they look they they are conditioned as
my generation was we were all we were
all anglophiles who looked to europe
beyond england i mean it was i mean it
was part of our you know eastern liberal
education
that ain't the case today
that is not the case today and the newer
members particularly
particularly from the midwestern and
western states
their economies of their states
are tied much more to asia than they are
to europe they look west not east i know
you probably think that's an
exaggeration but i i'm not joking about
that or they look south
and tie that to this resentment that
exists
this resentment that they don't quite
understand
why why
you know let me back up
a lot of you all of many of you knew
hubert humphrey
first time i ever went to europe i went
with hubert humphrey clifford case jack
javits mike mansfield
and i went to the ditchley house the
disli foundation in that magnificent old
estate of of robert e lee and we sat in
that library how you know it well with
all those deer hanging in the wall with
expressions written under their uh
fascinating play and i sat there and it
was an atlantic alliance meeting
and i sat there as a young 30 year old
senator and i just listened to these
people
and at the end of the three-day
conference dennis healey who was a very
very close friend of uh
believe it or not this is an answer
general um a very very close friend of
uh of of uh hubert humphreys
they were starting to engage in as all
the brits do rye toast and we have like
50 toast at this concluding dinner
and the concluding toast after hubert
humphrey got up and and just really went
after dennis healey in a humorous way
healy who was
a quite a quite a good after dinner
speaker stood up and toasted hubert
humphrey and he said and let me conclude
by saying
what
what uh
winston once said immediately after
becoming pm and i may get the names
wrong here but this is my recollection
he said
winston churchill was
at the box making an important point in
case and all of a sudden a young
backbencher in his own party stood up
and excoriated churchill
and i believe the name was psalms but
i'm not certain of that
no no
i don't know who it was well let me just
say smith
and old smith stands up and excoriates
churchill
and churchill generally looked across
the aisle or next to him but the name
that was in tone was at least clement i
don't know why some says that of me i
never did a favor for him
[Music]
well i think that's whoever said it
it shows great insight into human nature
and i think what's happening now
is every european leader knows the truth
of what we all know
that they desperately need and want us
to remain active and involved in europe
even the french as barry goldwater would
say in their heart they know we're right
but
but i cannot underestimate for you
overestimate for you
the impact upon my colleagues
of the lectures
of the flagellation
of the moralizing
that they get when they visit european
capitals
and they come back angry
i mean that sincerely you think i'm
joking i am not they come back
angry and so
i just think general it cannot be
underestimated the sense of resentment
and and you know it's kind of an irony
there was a there was a major poll
recently done why is it that with the
economy booming like it hasn't in 50
years in the sustained fashion why is it
with unemployment the lowest it has been
and and inflation the lowest and the
combination of all those factors as good
as why are americans still
pessimistic
when you ask them about their own
circumstance
and i believe part of this is that
americans are feeling sorry for
themselves right now they feel put upon
they feel as though we are the only ones
left standing we're the ones in their
minds that are always asked to do
everything whether it's true or not i
believe that's the feeling
and it is reflected in their elect in
their representative elected
representatives and so when the
europeans
with economies as strong as vibrant as
real
as ours
in terms of their long-term stability
come along and tell us about
our obligation
they get very angry
i'll give you a specific example i was
in one country in question
i asked one of the i believe it was the
deputy foreign minister
of this country the foreign minister was
there as well
and i believe the chairman of their
equivalent of the joint chiefs was there
and i was asked how are you going to pay
for
the ride the ticket
because that's the phrase they were
using
and they said oh our economy is growing
at six to seven percent a year and we're
going to do this that and then
we are going to raise a hundred million
dollars a year for allowing your forces
to exercise in our country
no i said god's truth i'm not joking
i am not joking
and i said uh well you know um
uh i think i i'm not joking about this
i said i think that will be a big
problem
and this particular
this particular deputy foreign minister
said but it's only and he came up with a
percentage one-half of one percent or
whatever of your military budget and you
have an obligation
and we are going to provide more
security and i so i avoid getting
letters i will not mention the country
i looked at this person i couldn't
resist and said now let me ask you a
question
how many americans do you think when i
go home
and say
your army is protecting their security
are going to sleep more soundly the next
night
well he didn't quite understand that
until i said that
and he said well what's the problem
and i said the problem is
that's not the way to sell make your
case
americans are tired of hearing this
i heard as recently as today
well my people expect you to keep your
commitment we've been waiting for the
americans to come for 50 years
i mean literally
that was the exact quote
now it's true they have been it's true
we've said we were but it is not true
that the american public is going to say
golly we got our chance now
let's go do it
and the other part of it general is just
like i'm sitting in each of those
capitalists as you have general and
you've forgotten more about this and i'm
going to learn
and not a single one of the countries
seeking admission feel the least bit
threatened at this moment not a single
one
and i try to make the case to them
i said wait a minute now you don't feel
threatened
why do you think the american people
after you tell them their obligation
are going to rush to the opportunity to
spend another couple hundred million
bucks a year
and if you don't feel threatened why
should they feel threatened
well it is it is understandable all this
is understandable
it's the politics of existing
but it is very corrosive
and that's why the last point general
is the reason i fear
the debate the most
is that if the europeans and
those countries seeking admission
do not forthrightly acknowledge to their
people the cost for them
and the price they will have to pay
if they expect us to pick up a
disproportionate share
this place will not swallow it
and it would be a tragic mistake
a tragic mistake
but you know
i went to a i went to a catholic school
and as it will shock you all i often got
in trouble
and the nuns used to make you
when you misbehaved
right on the board after school
times or 300 times it's usually for me
500
the following phrase several phrases but
one i remember because i've written it
thousands of times
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions
the good intentions of all our friends
who will tell us about
our obligations
may very well help pave the road to hell
which is that it could bring about
this worst case i don't expect it
but i'm telling you
it's going to be a major part of the
debate
you may recall general or maybe you
weren't there but i made a case to the
president a number of other people i
said you are misplacing your concern
your concern is whether or not the
center and the right in this country are
going to rebel against a nato
russian charter
i predict that that would not be the
problem
the problem is going to be
burden-sharing
that's going to be the problem
and that's why i think general it will
be a difficult debate we have time for
one more question yes sir
turkish probe magazine sir i'm so glad
you ended your uh uh speech or point
with your time i'm delighted that uh i
want to continue on the burden sharing
yes the southern flank of europe
nato is in the case of turkey is
expecting their threat immediate threat
coming from different directions than
that of central or eastern europe or
even in the case of russia
while they have limited resources for
their defense
how should their uh politicians explain
to their people spend their money where
there is no threat is at this point
while they're expecting the threat from
elsewhere so how should they really
honestly get up and say yes i will 100
share the burden whatever it comes to my
direction uh
two ways i and i again i said at the
outset i never tell another man is
politics so i will answer the question
by saying were i
were i a turkish official
the way i would or were i working for a
turkish official the way i would
recommend my boss to respond
i would say one answer is going to be a
bit to use the american slang a bit
flippant and the other answer is very
sincere
the first answer is
the sincerity
and that is that
that's why we have to redefine the
mission of nato
the redefinition of
nato's mission
and rationale for being has to in part
be to be have a capacity and a consensus
to deal with
something other than historically we
have only the european theater that's
number one and that's where i direct my
energies and the second i would say save
money by withdrawing your troops from
cyprus
and
bring them home i mean that sincerely i
am not joking about that um uh but then
again um i am not likely to win any
awards uh for popularity in turkey um
and uh nor many other countries uh but
but i'm sincere i really mean that i
think it is the festering boil
that should be lanced for the sake of
turkey
for the sake of turkey
as well as for cyprus
i really do
anyway um uh if i could exercise the
ferocity of the chair and ask i think
susan eisenhower has one
thank you very much for your
presentation i just thought there was
one other piece of unfinished business
you said earlier in your discussion well
what about the baltics well what about
the baltics if you could tell us what
their prospects are for expansion what
about the baltics what are their
prospects their prospects are real but
more distant
and i think this is me and only me
speaking not speaking for the
administration or anyone else in the
united states congress
and uh and i i obviously to state the
obvious i could be dead wrong about this
i think the one
place where the greatest consternation
would be caused in the short term
for admission
having nothing to do with the merit and
preparedness of the country to come in
would be to admit the baltic states now
in terms of nato russian u.s russian
relations
and if there was ever anything that was
going to tip the balance were to be
tipped
in terms of a vigorous and hostile
reaction i don't mean military
in russia it would be that
so the way i look at the calculus here
this eisenhower is as follows
i believe
and
i once was told that to be in this
business you must be an optimist
so some would suggest this is too
optimistic of you i believe time
time meaning in the next several years
will solve this so the degree to which
russia
becomes comfortable with
and it has demonstrated that the
enlargement of nato is not only not in
their interest but ultimately in their
interest in in expanding stability
is the greek the degree to which
the accession of the baltics into nato
becomes a reality
i think there's a correlation between
the two
and so it is my expectation as well as
my hope
that in the near term
meaning by the end of this century or
shortly thereafter
the balts
will be
admitted to nato if they still are
seeking admission to nato i expect they
will be
i expect they will be
so
there seems to me at least in the
calculus to be a correlation between the
two if we do the first piece well
then the second piece becomes inevitable
in my view
now there are others who will suggest
that that is not the case and we should
move for immediate admission of the
baltics that will also cause some real
difficulty within europe one of the
things everybody forgets
is we've got to get
16 votes including 15 plus rs 15 plus
r's
so to use an old phrase that was used
all during the 60s and 70s that maybe is
ironically relevant today there is there
are confidence building measures that
are going to be undertaken as a
consequence of this assession process
so in my view
they can and will be admitted in my view
it relates though to the calculus of how
well we do the first piece and the
reaction and the continued
democratization and market economy in
russia
i thank you all very very much for
allowing me to speak
senator thank you very much for a superb
presentation we're deeply in your dad
the czech republic hungary and poland
are the three u.s choices for nato
membership
a final announcement will be issued at
the nato summit in madrid spain in early
july
if there's a public affairs event in
your area you think we should cover call
our c-span events line area code
202-626-7963
you can also fax us at 202-737-6226
or contact us by email